This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。欢迎收听Look Back at It播客。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。对我也很有意义。我是Sam J.，我是Alex English。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at It。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
您正在收听由您最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games主持的Learn the Hard Way。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着铠甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA Radio App、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听和学习Learn the Hard Way。2023年，《单身汉》明星Clayton Eckerd被指控生育了双胞胎。但这段怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
Ellen女士，您捏造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吗？我捏造了一次检测。这花了一大批互联网侦探才发现了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。Greg、一个女同性恋者、Michael Ranjini。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是Stephanie Young。这是Love Trapped。Laura，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，Laura Owens终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。
Hello, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the very unprofessional podcast, whereby I, your unqualified guide, talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s. and what they mean for our psychology. Well, okay, it's been a big week. First week of August has absolutely blown by.
你好，欢迎回到Your 20s的心理学，这是一个非常不专业的播客，由我这个不合格的向导，带大家探讨我们20多岁时的一些重大变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么。好吧，这真是重要的一周。八月的第一周转瞬即逝。
And we're also halfway through the year, which is insane. Time is moving people. I'm having a flipping marvelous time of it all. I also just wanted to quickly start off by saying a big thank you to all those who have been listening to my podcast so far. I don't know, this is a real passion project for me. I love talking about these concepts and getting to deep dive into the psychological theory behind their occurrence, especially in our 20s. So I'm really, really grateful that people actually are finding it interesting and want to listen to me, Ramble.
而且我们已经度过了一年的一半，这太疯狂了。时光飞逝，朋友们。我过得真是美妙极了。我还想借此机会，向所有一直以来收听我播客的人表达由衷的感谢。我不知道，这对我来说是一个真正的热情项目。我喜欢谈论这些概念，并深入探讨其发生背后的心理学理论，特别是在我们的20多岁。所以我真的非常感激大家觉得它很有趣，并愿意听我唠叨。
And thanks for all the messages and the love. It just means a lot. And if you have feedback, please send it my way. I obviously want to hear it. And just a huge thanks to everyone who has already reached out. So that sappy, happy side out of the way, this week we're going to be talking about the green monster, so jealousy. Not only is it an amazing Olivia Rodrigo song, but it's also a really bloody interesting topic to look into as someone who I would say often gets that jealous surge at times. So hopefully I can spread some cool knowledge about what I have discovered in my time reading up on this.
谢谢大家的所有留言和爱意。这对我意义重大。如果您有任何反馈，请发给我。我非常希望能听到。非常感谢所有已经联系我的人。闲话少说，本周我们要谈论的是绿色怪物，也就是嫉妒。这不仅是一首精彩的Olivia Rodrigo的歌，而且作为一个有时会经常感到这种嫉妒激增的人来说，探讨这个话题也是一件非常有趣的事情。所以希望我能传播一些我在阅读相关资料时发现的酷炫知识。
Yeah, and just kind of investigating jealousy. Also a big shout out to friend of the show, Carolina, for suggesting this episode on the poll I ran on my Instagram a few weeks ago. I thought this just would be a great concept to break down, particularly for those in their 20s. I think jealousy is a weird emotion. And really being able to break down why it's so intense, why it leaves us feeling so icky is important so that, you know, A, we don't feel bad when we do get jealous. And B, we can kind of manage it and ensure that it doesn't harm our, friendships, our relationships, and, you know, our overall well-being.
是的，也就是探讨嫉妒。还要特别感谢节目的朋友Carolina，几周前我在Instagram上发起投票时，是她建议了这个话题。我认为这是一个很好的概念，特别适合那些处于20多岁的人。我认为嫉妒是一种奇怪的情绪。能够真正剖析为什么它如此强烈，为什么它让我们感觉如此糟糕，这很重要，这样，你知道的，A，当我们感到嫉妒时，我们不会感到内疚。B，我们可以对其进行管理，并确保它不会损害我们的友谊、关系以及，你知道的，我们的整体幸福感。
Firstly, jealousy is a universal emotion. It's not just those in their 20s that have that weird pain of emotion or obsessiveness and insecurity in our relationships or towards another person, but young people are more prone to jealousy than any other age group, particularly those between the 19 and 26 age range. So there was this research done by the University of California and they found 80% of people aged 30 or under had felt an attack of the green-eyed monster, I guess, in the past year compared to just 69% of people over 50. So a real big age difference there,
首先，嫉妒是一种普遍的情绪。不仅仅是20多岁的人才会有那种奇怪的情绪痛楚，或者在恋爱关系中或对另一个人产生强迫症和不安全感，但年轻人比任何其他年龄组都更容易产生嫉妒，特别是19岁到26岁之间的人。加利福尼亚大学曾做过这样一项研究，他们发现30岁及以下的人中有80%在过去一年中曾感受到绿眼怪物的袭击，相比之下，50岁以上的人中这一比例仅为69%。所以这里有一个非常大的年龄差异，
or just a difference in frequency, I guess, amongst different age groups. I think especially when we're young and in love or just feeling more vulnerable, jealousy can be a lot more common, especially in romantic relationships, but also friendships or towards people. we may not even know. And jealousy, it's not just about love or being protective of a relationship. We can feel jealous of basically anything, you know, looks, possessions, as well as obviously our partners and friends. But what really often drives jealousy is, unfortunately, something a little bit
或者只是不同年龄组之间的频率差异。我认为特别是当我们年轻、坠入爱河，或者只是感到更加脆弱时，嫉妒会更加普遍，尤其是在恋爱关系中，但也可能发生在友谊中，或者针对我们甚至不认识的人。嫉妒并不仅仅关乎爱情或对关系的保护欲。我们基本上对任何事情都会感到嫉妒，你知道的，外表、财产，以及显然还有我们的伴侣和朋友。但真正驱动嫉妒的，往往是不幸的是一些更深层次的东西
deeper. So low self-esteem and poor self-image is typically more common in those who report feeling more jealous towards those in their lives. And in one study, overwhelmingly, people actually envied others of their own gender more. So men envied other men and women envied other women more consistently, even in domains like financial and occupational success, where you can imagine that, you know, a woman might envy a man for his better pay or status. That usually wasn't the case. It's normally those who are the same gender that you identify as, that normally, that normally receive a great deal more of your envy or your jealousy. But like I kind of mentioned, jealousy, it often comes from a lack of security in what we have, or a lack of certainty or trust,
所以，低自尊和糟糕的自我形象通常在那些报告对自己生活中的人感到更嫉妒的人中更常见。在一项研究中，绝大多数人实际上更嫉妒自己同性的人。因此，男性更嫉妒其他男性，女性更嫉妒其他女性，甚至在财务和职业成功等领域也是如此，你可能会想象，一个女性可能会因为男性的更高薪水或地位而嫉妒他。通常情况并非如此。通常是你所认同的同性别的人，通常会收到你更多的嫉妒。但就像我提到的那样，嫉妒往往来自于对我们所拥有东西缺乏安全感，或者缺乏确定性或信任，
especially in the case of relationships. And yeah, it can be a pretty terrible feeling and create problems, but it's so important not to suppress feelings of jealousy, especially when we're young, because in this time, we do have the opportunity to examine the origins of the emotion before it becomes a pattern of our behavior and a pattern of our thought. That's why I think it is so crucial to discuss it in relation to 20-something year olds. You know, in this time of our lives, we have all these new experiences. We're learning what a relationship is, what boundaries we want for ourselves, we're establishing our sense of security and trust in ourselves and also those around us. So jealousy can be a real challenge, not just because it can be pretty common, but also because
特别是在恋爱关系中。是的，这可能是一种非常糟糕的感觉并产生问题，但不要压抑嫉妒的情绪是如此重要，特别是当我们年轻的时候，因为在这个时期，我们确实有机会在情绪成为我们的行为模式和思维模式之前，去审视它的根源。这就是为什么我认为讨论二十多岁年轻人的嫉妒问题如此至关重要。你知道，在我们生命的这个阶段，我们拥有所有这些新的体验。我们正在学习什么是恋爱关系，我们希望为自己设定什么界限，我们正在建立对自己以及周围人的安全感和信任感。所以嫉妒可能是一个真正的挑战，不仅因为它很常见，而且因为
none of us want to be, you know, that jealous person in any situation, you know, the jealous girlfriend or the jealous boyfriend. So let's examine the psychology of jealousy. Why is this green monster such a hard one to shake off? Where does it kind of come from? Where does it emerge from? And what's the purpose of jealousy? How can we acknowledge, address and move on from jealousy before or it kind of creates havoc in our personal lives or leads to us sacrificing amazing relationships intimately and otherwise. Okay, so let's clear one thing up firstly. Although I've kind of already said this, jealousy is an entirely natural emotion to feel.
我们谁都不想在任何情况下成为那种人，你知道的，嫉妒的女朋友或嫉妒的男朋友。让我们来审视一下嫉妒的心理学。为什么这个绿色怪物这么难以摆脱？它到底是从哪里来的？它是从哪里出现的？嫉妒的目的是什么？在我们个人生活中引发混乱或导致我们牺牲亲密及其他方面美妙的关系之前，我们该如何承认、应对并超越嫉妒？好吧，首先让我们澄清一件事。尽管我之前已经说过，嫉妒是一种完全自然的情绪。
It's not a primary emotion. It's rather the combination of a number of other primary emotions, which we might be a little bit better at recognizing. So let's just make up a scenario. So imagine you've been talking with this guy, this girl, person of your choosing. Maybe it's best to kind of close your eyes and picture someone that you've really liked at some stage or maybe you currently like them. Someone that you've been talking to, maybe you just really vibe with them. You have good chemistry, love spending time with them and maybe you're hoping it will go further. Maybe you'll end up dating or something like that. But basically, you really like them.
它不是一种原初情绪。它更像是其他几种原初情绪的组合，对于这些情绪我们可能更容易识别。让我们假设一个场景。所以想象你一直在和这个男生、这个女生、你选择的人聊天。也许最好闭上眼睛，想象一个你在某个阶段真的很喜欢的人，或者你目前正喜欢的人。一个你一直在交谈的人，也许你和他们真的很合拍。你们有很好的化学反应，喜欢和他们共度时光，也许你希望这段关系能更进一步。也许你们最终会约会或诸如此类。但基本上，你真的很喜欢他们。
And imagine that feeling of just being consumed by someone, thinking about them constantly. Then you see them with someone else. Probably most likely in Braden or at fucking Dixon Woolies. Different with Cambridge coincidence. This obviously has happened to me before. But you see them with someone else. And you just can imagine that feeling for a second, that heart swelling mixture of anger, of anxiety. and sadness, it's pretty terrible.
想象那种被一个人吞噬的感觉，脑子里全是他们。然后你看到他们和别人在一起。很可能在布雷登（Braden）或者该死的迪克森Woolies（Dixon Woolies）。剑桥的巧合有所不同。这显然以前发生在我身上。但你看到他们和别人在一起。你可以想象一下那种感觉，那种愤怒、焦虑和悲伤交织的汹涌心绪，这太糟糕了。
And yeah, we kind of need to realize, like, what is the emotional core of jealousy? We can recognize that feeling. I know we've probably all felt jealous of something in our lives before, but jealousy is not one emotion. You know, you're not just jealous. It's a combination of two primary emotions that kind of create our overall emotional state. So firstly, there is anxiety or fear.
是的，我们需要意识到，嫉妒的情感核心是什么？我们可以识别那种感觉。我知道我们生活中可能都对某事感到过嫉妒，但嫉妒并不是单一的情绪。你知道，你不只是嫉妒。它是两种原初情绪的结合，共同创造了我们整体的情绪状态。首先，是焦虑或恐惧。
mostly around losing something, something being taken from you or not being able to attain something that you would like. And this fear or anxiety is what creates that initial, almost nervous gut feeling, increased heart rate, and just general discomfort. And then the anger tends to come next, almost as a defense towards your fear. So the anger is often what the main,
主要围绕失去某物、某物被夺走，或者无法获得你想要的东西。这种恐惧或焦虑正是最初那种几乎紧张的肠胃感觉、心率加快和普遍不适的原因。接下来往往是愤怒，几乎是对你的恐惧的一种防御。所以愤怒往往是主要的，
what is that main feeling that we have when feeling jealous. And you may also feel a lot of, out and dread. And I also read another study, which was a bit more new. It was a newer study. And they suggested that jealousy might also be made up of grief, so not just fear and anger, but grief or just this like momentary pain at the thought of losing a loved object or person. And because these emotions are so strong, they can often carry with us. It's not just a momentary emotional state. Things like grief, as we know, they don't leave. once you felt it for a couple of minutes. So that's why jealousy can kind of travel with us through a
我们感到嫉妒时的主要感觉是什么。你可能还会感到很多恐惧和畏惧。我还读了另一项研究，这是一项比较新的研究。他们提出嫉妒可能还由悲伤组成，不仅仅是恐惧和愤怒，还有悲伤，或者在想到失去心爱的物品或人时产生的那种短暂的痛苦。因为这些情绪如此强烈，它们往往会伴随着我们。这不仅仅是一种短暂的情绪状态。正如我们所知，悲伤等情绪在你体验了几分钟后并不会消失。这就是为什么嫉妒会伴随着我们穿越
relationship even after, you know, an issue has been talked about or rectified. But I think the other thing to make very clear is jealousy is never intentional. It's simply the emotion or the combination of emotions that we feel when we suspect losing something we cherish. And it can be triggered by heaps of factors, but we can see why it's common in relationship settings, especially when we're young and those losses can be so raw and new. So this threat will often come from, you know, a third party. And it can make someone feel as if they're being replaced. So our brains do commonly link jealousy to romantic relationships.
一段关系，甚至在问题被讨论或纠正之后也是如此。但我认为需要非常明确的另一件事是，嫉妒从不是故意的。它纯粹是我们怀疑失去珍视之物时感受到的情绪或情绪组合。它可以由多种因素触发，但我们可以看出为什么它在恋爱关系中很常见，尤其是当我们年轻且这些失落感如此原始和崭新时。因此，这种威胁通常来自第三方。这会让人觉得自己正在被取代。所以我们的大脑通常会将嫉妒与恋爱关系联系起来。
For example, a boyfriend who starts an argument when his girlfriend gets a text from another man or maybe we run into an ex and, you know, they've got someone new with them. These are common triggers for a jealous person. but we can feel threatened in relationships that aren't romantic as well. You know, friendships, co-workers, family members is also a big one, especially siblings that are close in age, I found. There's a really interesting study that showed larger families or families with lots of siblings or kids close in age
例如，当女友收到另一个男人的短信时开始争吵的男友，或者我们偶遇前任，你知道，他们身边有了新的人。这些是嫉妒者的常见诱惑。但我们在非恋爱关系中也可能感到受威胁。你知道，友谊、同事、家庭成员也是一个大问题，尤其是年龄相仿的兄弟姐妹，我发现。有一项非常有趣的研究表明，大家庭或拥有许多兄弟姐妹或年龄相近孩子的家庭
are more likely to report greater instances of jealousy within the family dynamic. But this all kind of happens when we're young. And as we get older, we do understand jealousy, a bit better, especially because we've been able to navigate it in the past or having had experiences that have taught us what to expect. But if you're always, if you always handle jealousy by first letting the anger take over and seeking to avoid the pain by ignoring those feelings or acting in something or from some place other than your wise mind, then you will create a behavioral pattern in reaction to these feelings. So when you feel threatened, this acts as
更有可能报告家庭内部发生嫉妒的几率更高。但这一切都是在我们年轻时发生的。随着年龄的增长，我们确实能更好地理解嫉妒，特别是由于我们过去能够驾驭它，或者有过教会我们预期什么的经验。但如果你总是通过首先让愤怒占据主导地位，并通过忽视这些感受或基于明智头脑之外的某种立场行事来逃避痛苦，那么你就会在对这些感受的反应中创造一种行为模式。所以当你感到受威胁时，这就起到了
as a trigger. So behavioural models in psychology explain this really, really well. So behaviourism is the kind of area that probably best relates to this. So at first, threatening situations that create jealousy act as the unconditioned stimulus. So essentially we naturally feel angry and anxious, perhaps experienced grief if, you know, our partner was talking to other people or someone we know got a job we really wanted. However, say that your reaction to that jealousy is to cut these people off. It's to suppress the emotion, not address it. After this reaction is repeatedly paired with the jealous feelings over time, soon we'll just behave this way unconsciously without even realizing it. So you start to even avoid situations where you believe
触发器的作用。因此，心理学中的行为主义模型对此进行了解释，真的非常非常好。所以行为主义是与此最相关的领域。首先，产生嫉妒的威胁性情况充当了无条件刺激。本质上，如果我们的伴侣和其他人说话，或者我们认识的人得到了我们真正想要的工作，我们自然会感到愤怒和焦虑，或许会经历悲伤。然而，假设你对这种嫉妒的反应是切断与这些人的联系。是压抑情绪，而不是解决它。在这种反应与嫉妒情绪随着时间反复配对之后，很快我们就会在不知不觉中无意识地以这种方式行事。所以你甚至开始逃避那些你认为
you might be made to feel jealous, so avoiding relationships or leaving the moment that you you feel like you're not valued or there's someone to be envious of. So it can become pretty easy to be what we know as a jealous person. But as some people, they are more prone to jealousy than others. So psychological factors that lead to a jealous personality type may include low self-esteem, which we talked about. So a sense of inadequacy is often a cause of jealousy that isn't relationship dependent. people who feel inadequate don't present their sense of personal impotence in relationships alone.
可能会让你感到嫉妒的情况，所以逃避恋爱关系，或者在你觉得自己不被重视或有让人羡慕的人出现时立刻离开。因此，成为我们所知的嫉妒的人变得很容易。但对某些人来说，他们比其他人更容易产生嫉妒。因此，导致嫉妒型人格的心理因素可能包括低自尊，我们讨论过。因此，无能感往往是与恋爱关系无关的嫉妒的原因。感到无能的人并不仅仅在恋爱关系中表现出他们的无能感。
And this suggests that it has a lot more to do with a person's reflection of themselves more than just sexual or intimate possessiveness. Some other factors which have been consistently linked to a jealous personality type is anxiety, moodiness, depression. If you've got possessiveness, insecurities, a fear of abandonment, which I really want to talk about in an upcoming episode, because I think it would be really interesting. If you have a tendency towards codependency as well, and kind of alongside that fear of abandonment, if you have an anxious attachment style. So when someone's
这表明，这与一个人对自己的反思有很大关系，而不仅仅是性或亲密占有欲。其他一些与嫉妒型人格始终相关的因素包括焦虑、情绪化、抑郁。如果你有占有欲、不安全感、对被抛弃的恐惧（我想在即将播出的节目中好好聊聊这个，因为我认为会非常有趣）。如果你也有共依赖的倾向，以及伴随着对被抛弃的恐惧，如果你有焦虑型依恋风格。所以当某人的
personality is perhaps dominated by any or all of these factors, jealousy, it's not likely going to be a foreign emotion for them. And this can make it hard to have long-lasting and meaningful relationships, you know, both romantic and in the friend's sense when we are in our 20s, especially if you have acquired that learned response to situations that stir up jealous feelings. Okay, so far we've really demonstrated how jealousy is very much a relational combination of emotions. So it emerges primarily in response to our social relationships with others, particularly close relationships, such as friendships or romantic connections. And I've really tried to stress my perspective, at least, that jealousy is a natural emotional state, in its pure form, at least.
人格可能由这些因素中的任何一个或全部主导时，嫉妒对他们来说可能不会是一个陌生的情绪。这会让我们在20多岁时很难建立持久且有意义的关系，无论是在浪漫关系还是朋友关系方面，特别是如果你已经对那些激起嫉妒情绪的情境获得了这种条件反射般的反应。好的，到目前为止，我们已经真正展示了嫉妒在很大程度上是如何成为一种关系性的情绪组合的。它主要作为对我们与他人社会关系的反应而出现，特别是亲密关系，例如友谊或浪漫连接。我真的极力强调我的观点，至少在纯粹的形式下，嫉妒是一种自然的情绪状态。
But it then can slowly become cultivated and more prominent due to reinforcing behaviors. So if my interpretation is correct, not saying that it is, but this is just what I've kind of gathered. Envy and jealousy, they are intrinsic and can be very very very. very powerful emotions, yeah, but not those that we need to flee from or feel embarrassed by as long as we communicate with others and react to those twinges from a wise mind, as my therapist would say. Shout out to Josie, but not an emotional mind. So a wise mind is the best way to go about dealing with feelings of jealousy. But let's offer another perspective. We're not one-sided on this show. We all know that in our 20s relationships, they don't all tend to look
但它随后可以通过强化的行为慢慢地被培养和变得更加突出。如果我的理解是正确的，并不是说一定对，但这只是我所收集到的。嫉妒和羡慕是内生的，可以是非常非常非常强大的情绪，是的，但只要我们与他人沟通，并像我的治疗师所说的那样，用明智的头脑去对这些隐痛做出反应，而不是逃避它们或对此感到尴尬。向Josie致敬，但不要用情绪化的头脑去应对。因此，明智的头脑是处理嫉妒情绪的最佳方式。但让我们提供另一个视角。我们在这个节目中并不是片面的。我们都知道，在我们20多岁的关系中，它们并不都往往看起来像
the same way. There's a lot more freedom to be experimental or do things differently, whether that's by keeping a relationship open, being poly, friends with benefits. It's no longer the standard man and woman, girlfriend and boyfriend situation for many, many reasons. And I think especially during this time, you know, why don't you keep a relationship open if it's something that you both feel comfortable with? You know, we're young. There are a lot of people out there to love. And we have our whole lives to be coupled with one person if that's inevitably what you decide to do. So the reason I'm introducing, you know, poly and open relationships is because it kind of provides a counter argument to this idea that jealousy is intrinsic.
也是一样的。现在有更多自由去进行实验或者用不同的方式行事，无论是保持开放式关系、多元之爱，还是友谊福利。出于很多很多原因，这不再是标准的男人和女人、女朋友和男朋友的情况。而且我认为尤其是在这个时候，你知道，如果这是你们两个都觉得舒服的事情，为什么不保持开放式关系呢？你知道，我们还年轻。外面有很多可以去爱的人。如果这不可避免地是你决定要做的事，我们有一生的时间跟一个人绑定。所以我引入多元之爱和开放式关系的原因是，它为“嫉妒是天生的”这一观点提供了一点反驳。
So poly and open relationships, they're not a new thing. You know, non-monogamy dates all the way back to BCA times. There's evidence that's existed in Rome, China, Mongolia. also permitted in a number of religions, obviously Islam, where it's acceptable to have up to four wives, but obviously also in the Mormon faith as well. But it hasn't been, you know, all around very accepted or welcomed in the previous century, just in everyday life. And, you know, until now, you know, it wasn't really something that people looked into, whereas these days, you know, you probably could find people who have this type of relationship and it really works for them.
所以多元之爱和开放式关系并不是什么新鲜事。你知道，非一夫一妻制可以追溯到公元前。有证据表明它存在于罗马、中国、蒙古。它也在许多宗教中被允许，显然伊斯兰教可以接受多达四个妻子，但显然也在摩门教信仰中。但在上个世纪的日常生活中，它并没有被普遍接受或欢迎。而且，直到现在，它真的不是人们会去研究的东西，而如今，你可能会找到拥有这种类型关系的人，它真的对他们很管用。
Also, I think it's probably important to recognize that historical and modern polyamory, they're very different things. You know, historical non-monogamy, it was primarily for the purpose of procreation or reproduction, whereas now it can be for more reasons than just that. Okay, that was a bit of a historical tangent or digression, the purpose of which was to introduce the idea that perhaps jealousy is not natural in romantic relationships, as I've previously suggested. So polyamorous couples are often able to know that their partner was with other people and not experience jealousy. And people in poly relationships tend to hold the idea that jealousy is actually culturally instilled to us, especially at a young age and in Western societies where being envious of people can make us more competitive, which helps motivate success and accumulation, which are things of a lot of value in many Western cultures. much like a lot of the psychological theory suggests people in healthy polyamorous relationships
另外，我认为认识到历史上的多边恋和现代的多边恋是非常不同的东西可能很重要。你知道，历史上的非一夫一妻制，它主要是为了生育或繁衍的目的，而现在它可以出于不仅仅是那样的更多原因。好吧，那是一个有点历史离题或旁白，其目的是引入这样一种想法，即嫉妒在恋爱关系中可能并非天生，正如我之前所建议的那样。因此，多边恋情侣通常能够知道他们的伴侣和别人在一起而不会体验到嫉妒。处在多元关系中的人倾向于认为，嫉妒实际上是文化灌输给我们的，尤其是在年轻的时候，在西方社会中，对人们心怀嫉妒可以让我们更具竞争力，这有助于激发成功和积累，这些在许多西方文化中是非常有价值的东西。就像很多心理学理论所暗示的那样，处于健康多边恋关系中的人
may view jealousy more as an indication of a deeper sense of insecurity that has been created you know by this deeper social narrative rather than being due to some innate sense of sexual possessiveness or jealousy that you know an evolutionary perspective might might say is the case And this has some pretty surprising evidence that suggests jealousy may be cultural and socially specific. So one study hypothesized that aggression and jealousy situations, it's correlated with the cultural importance attached to being married. The limitations placed on non-marital and extramarital sexual gratification. It's also linked to the emphasis of private property within a society and the requirements. of personal descendants.
可能会将嫉妒更多地视为由于这种更深层次的社会叙事而产生的不安全感的更深层迹象，而不是由于某种天生的性占有欲或嫉妒，而从进化视角可能会说情况就是这样。这有一些相当令人惊奇的证据，表明嫉妒可能是文化和社会特定的。因此，一项研究假设，攻击和嫉妒的情况，它与对结婚这一行为的文化重视程度相关。对非婚和婚外性满足的限制。它还与社会中对私有财产的强调以及个人后代的硬性要求有关。
So in societies where these social ideas are not dominant, feelings of jealousy are suspected to be less. And furthermore, in male-dominated societies, jealousy was likely to be more common amongst all genders as well. This was another thing that they suggested. And the findings did show that in cultures that were less focused on these certain characteristics of the social fabric, such as being married and having offspring,
因此，在这些社会观念并不占主导地位的社会中，人们怀疑嫉妒感会减少。此外，在男性主导的社会中，各性别的嫉妒也可能更常见。这是他们提出的另一件事。调查结果确实表明，在那些较少关注社会结构的这些特定特征（例如结婚和生育后代）的文化中，
jealousy was less, particularly of the four cultures that researchers examined Thai men and women were less likely to express jealousy, as were pre-industrial communities or those where, obviously, polyamory is the cultural norm. I think it is important to say, though, although these groups did experience less jealousy, it was not at a level of being completely,
嫉妒更少，特别是研究人员检查的四种文化中，泰国男女表达嫉妒的可能性较小，前工业化社区或显然多元之爱是文化规范的社区也是如此。不过，我认为必须说明的是，尽管这些群体确实经历了较少的嫉妒，但它并没有达到完全不存在的程度。
non-existent. So jealousy, although it's culturally influenced in the frequency and intensity of expression, it does still seem to be universal in nature. Okay, so if you're in your 20s and you're feeling that jealousy spike when you see your friends hanging out or, you know, your partner's messaging someone else or a co-worker is getting more attention from your boss. Do not fret for two reasons. Firstly, feelings of jealousy are natural. They're attached to some of our most fundamental emotions. And secondly, it's equally not your fault due to elements of our culture and that emphasis on possession as well as, or possession is more so as an attribute of success and dominance.
因此，嫉妒虽然在表达的频率和强度上受到文化影响，但它本质上似乎仍然是普遍存在的。好吧，如果你二十几岁，当你看到朋友聚在一起，或者，你知道的，你的伴侣给别人发信息，或者一个同事从你老板那里得到更多关注时，你感到了嫉妒激增。不要为此苦恼，原因有二。首先，嫉妒的感觉是自然的。它们附着在我们最基本的一些情绪上。其次，由于我们文化中的元素以及对占有的强调，以及将占有更多地视为成功和统治的属性，这同样也不是你的错。
So this fuels the need to have feelings of jealousy in order to motivate us to hold on to things that we see as having value. obviously this does not give anyone listening the permission or the excuse to move into the territory of being pathologically jealous so pathological jealousy it's when these feelings become clinical it's also sometimes known as delusional disorder look into it it's it's kind of like a form of schizoaffective disorder and it occurs when people have these intrusive and repetitive but crucially they're unfounded. They have these repetitive ideas that their romantic partner is cheating on them,
因此，这助长了产生嫉妒感的需求，以便激励我们去抓紧那些我们视为具有价值的事物。显然，这并没有给任何听众权力或借口进入病态嫉妒的领域。病态嫉妒，当这些感觉演变成临床症状时，它有时也被称为妄想性障碍。了解一下，它有点像分裂情感障碍的一种形式，当人们产生这些侵入性和重复性，但至关重要的是毫无根据的想法时就会发生。他们有这些反复出现的想法，认为他们的浪漫伴侣在对他们不忠，
essentially leading to increasingly possessive behavior. But there's no evidence of that. It's a delusion, hence delusional disorder. But it's really hard to treat. You know, these people have an unnatural pattern of thinking that has breached the territory of needing treatment, and they very rarely have control over these jealous delusions.
本质上导致了日益具有占有欲的行为。但没有证据表明这一点。这是一种妄想，因此叫妄想性障碍。但它真的很难治疗。你知道，这些人有一种不自然的思维模式，已经跨入了需要治疗的领域，他们极少能控制这些嫉妒的妄想。
So it's a psychiatric disorder essentially. And although there is evidence that people can take antipsychotics, often the only way to overcome this disorder is to become comfortable with the idea that, you know, yes, your partner might be cheating on you, even if there is no evidence. So you kind of have to live in the idea that this could be true, but you're okay with it. And a therapist would want their patient to accept this as a possibility, but also to be able to move forward. So basically, the outcome for this disorder is that jealousy is never fully eliminated and it never really goes away you still have a distrust of the person that you're with you just learn to manage it better so that is a pretty
所以它本质上是一种精神疾病。尽管有证据表明人们可以服用抗精神病药物，但克服这种疾病的唯一方法往往是习惯于这样一种想法，即，是的，你的伴侣可能在对你不忠，即使没有任何证据。所以你有点不得不生活在“这可能是真的，但你没关系”的想法中。治疗师会希望他们的患者接受这种可能性作为现实，但也能够继续前进。所以基本上，这种疾病的结果是，嫉妒永远不会被完全消除，它也永远不会真正消失。你仍然对和你在一起的人缺乏信任，你只是学会了更好地管理它，所以这是一个相当
bleak outlook but then again we are talking about a disordered version of jealousy so for the average joe in their 20s or whatever age you might be jealousy can be reduced and no you do not need antipsychotics to do it, fortunately enough. So seeing as jealousy can be brought on by so many varying factors, there's no really standard cure for the emotion. And in my opinion, I think if you can manage it in a healthy manner, it's not actually something to be avoided. Otherwise, you do end up losing control of the emotion.
暗淡的前景。但话又说回来，我们讨论的是嫉妒的一种失调版本。所以对于二十多岁或无论你可能处于什么年龄的普通人来说，嫉妒是可以减少的，而且不，你不需要抗精神病药物来做到这一点，幸运的是。既然嫉妒可以由如此多的不同因素引发，那么这种情绪就没有真正的标准治疗方法。在我看来，如果你能以健康的方式管理它，它实际上并不是应该被避免的东西。否则，你最终会失去对这种情绪的控制。
And that's when it becomes a problem. You know, you cannot go through life, especially in such a social and relational world, without experiencing jealousy. So you may as well become accustomed to dealing with it when you're in your 20s and have less to lose and heaps to learn. So I think just noting that the emotion exists and is clouding your brain is the most important part. So basic acknowledgement therapy, you know, you can self-administer. You don't have to go to headspace or anything. And jealousy, it's really normal and it can be pretty tricky to think to navigate when we're in our 20s.
那就是它成为问题的时候。你知道，你不能经历生活，尤其是在这样一个社交和关系的社会中，而不体验嫉妒。所以当你在二十多岁且输得少学得多的时候，你不如习惯于处理它。所以我认为只要注意到这种情绪的存在并且它正在扰乱你的大脑，就是最重要的一部分。所以基本的承认疗法，你知道的，你可以自己施行。你不必去headspace或任何地方。而且嫉妒，它真的很正常，当我们二十多岁时，它可能相当棘手去摸索。
For example, you know, I found out my ex has a new girlfriend and obviously there's some pretty intense jealousy followed with that. But understanding why I felt triggered and uncovering the emotions leading up to it, the insecurity that was creating this feeling was really, really useful. So when did I start feeling this way? Why do I feel threatened? Is it because I'm missing something and what part of my personality are involved in these feelings of jealousy? because I don't love this person anymore. I haven't been with them for a very long time. Why is it only now that that possessiveness is kind of clicking in? And I have this really good phrase that I use all the time.
例如，你知道，我发现我的前任有了新女朋友，随之而来的显然是一些相当强烈的嫉妒。但理解为什么我感到被触发，并揭开导致它的情绪，即造成这种感觉的不安全感，真的是非常非常有用的。那么我什么时候开始有这种感觉的？为什么我觉得受到威胁？是因为我错漏了什么，还是我的性格中哪一部分参与了这些嫉妒的感觉？因为我不再爱这个人了。我和他们在一起已经很久很久了。为什么直到现在这种占有欲才有点触发？我有一个经常使用的非常好的短语。
My friends know this, but I just think it's a really great way to explain this. And this is the phrase. If it still triggers you, if it still makes you jealous, then you still have some healing to do. Because jealousy, you know, it's coming from an internal place,
我的朋友们都知道这一点，但我只是认为这是解释这一点的绝佳方式。这就是这句话。如果它仍然触发你，如果它仍然让你嫉妒，那么你还有一些疗愈要做。因为嫉妒，你知道，它来自一个内在的地方，
or a sense of inadequacy. So addressing that root issue first will do, you know, wonders to lessen envy towards anyone, really. So, yeah, if it still triggers you, if it still makes you jealous, then you still have some healing to do. And there is no magical cure. Jealousy can be analysed and unlikely avoided in the future, yes, but it's never going to be completely eliminated. And if you would like to reach that point, I think it would just include heaps of mindfulness, There's a heap of therapy. You'd have to have a lot of honest and intimate conversations,
或者是一种不胜任感。所以首先解决这个根本问题，真的会对减少对任何人的嫉妒产生奇效。所以，是的，如果它仍然触发你，如果它仍然让你嫉妒，那么你还有一些疗愈要做。并且没有神奇的解药。嫉妒可以被分析并且在未来不太可能完全避免，是的，但它永远不会被完全消除。如果你想达到那个地步，我认为它只会包含大量的正念。有大量的疗愈。你必须进行很多诚实且亲密的对话，
which you're very much welcome to do, but it does seem like a bit of a, a bit of a challenge. You may as well just accept it, have those conversations and move on. And I know I have stress this heaps, and it can get a little bit preachy, but whether jealousy is culturally mediated or intrinsic,
虽然你非常欢迎这样做，但这确实看起来有点像挑战。你不如直接接受它，进行那些对话，然后继续前进。我知道我一直在强调这一点，这可能会变得有点爱说教，但无论嫉妒是文化介导的还是内在的，
whichever theory you choose to believe, it's not something that can be ignored. You know, if you approach the entirety of your younger years, simply looking to avoid pain or feelings of insecurity. What are you, you know, really getting out of your life? You know, the avoidance of pain, there's a trade-off for that. And the avoidance of jealousy, there's also a trade-off for that as well. So embrace a healthy amount of jealousy.
无论你选择相信哪种理论，它都不是可以被忽视的东西。你知道，如果你对待你年轻时的全部方式，仅仅是为了寻找避免痛苦或不安全感。你从你的生活中到底得到了什么？你知道，痛苦的回避，有一个权衡。而嫉妒的回避，也有一个权衡。所以拥抱适量的嫉妒。
Let it remind you of what you need to work on personally and internally. Don't just project it onto the actions of other people. But what is your ego trying to communicate to you? And move from there. Just be open, be honest. the feelings without kind of letting it fuck things up too much. So, yeah, a wise note to finish on. I think I always provide like this very considered life advice at the end,
让它提醒你需要对个人和内在进行什么调整。不要只是把它投射到其他人的行为上。但是你的自我试图跟你沟通什么？并从那里继续。只需保持开放，保持诚实。这些感受，而不至于让事情变得太糟糕。所以，是的，这是一个明智的收尾。我想我总是在最后提供这种非常深思熟虑的生活建议，
whereas I'm over here being like, I get jealous all the time, I'm not afraid to hide it. But yeah, there's my two cents on the topic. And I really hope you enjoyed this episode. It was really, really interesting to look into. I think because I've had these like feelings of jealousy recently. and it kind of got me down. I was like I'm not really a naturally jealous person.
而我却在这里表现得像，我一直都在嫉妒，我不怕隐藏它。但是，是的，这是我对这个话题的粗浅看法。我真的希望你喜欢这期节目。研究这个真的非常非常有趣。我想因为我最近有这种嫉妒的感觉。这让我很沮丧。我当时就想，我本来不是一个天生嫉妒的人。
Like I was saying, it was in relation to someone that I don't really care about anymore. You know, I don't really need them in my life. I've really moved on. But it was like a reminder of losing something that once I really valued. So, yeah, I did a lot of kind of self-acknowledgement therapy around it. And happy to report. I'm feeling you're okay now. But yeah, sorry, a little bit of a tangent.
就像我说的，这是关于一个我不再真正关心的人。你知道，我真的不需要他们在我的生活中。我已经真正前进了。但这就像是一个提醒，提醒我失去了曾经非常重视的东西。所以，是的，我围绕它做了很多自我承认疗愈。很高兴向大家汇报。我觉得你现在还好。但是，是的，抱歉，有点离题了。
Thanks for listening, by the way, if you're still here, getting all the juicy goss on my life. Also, if you are listening this far, let me know how the audio is because I've changed the thing that I'm recording it on and I'm sitting in a new location. So it might be kind of shit. Hopefully it's better. Just please let me know.
顺便谢谢你们的收听，如果你还在听的话，听到了关于我生活的各种八卦。另外，如果你一直听到这里，请让我知道音质怎么样，因为我更换了录音设备，而且我坐在一个新的地方。所以它可能有点糟糕。希望它会更好。请务必告诉我。
And remember to follow us on Instagram. And yeah, you can find this podcast wherever you get your podcast, Spotify. Apple Music, Google Podcasts even, and I hope you have an amazing second week of August. You know, it's 15 degrees today. The sun is coming. I'm very excited for some summer love and some, you know, summer outdoors time and drinks. So anyhow, have an amazing week. And then thank you so much for listening.
并且记得在Instagram上关注我们。是的，无论你在哪里收听播客，你都可以找到这个播客，Spotify。Apple Music，甚至Google Podcasts，我希望你们的八月第二周过得愉快。你知道，今天15度。太阳出来了。我对夏日的爱、夏日的户外时光和饮料感到非常兴奋。无论如何，祝大家有个美妙的一周。非常感谢你们的收听。
On the Look Back at it podcast. 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在《Look Back at it》播客中。1979年，那对我是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是Sam J。我是Alex English。这一集里，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试着弄清楚我们是如何在朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家的陪伴下熬过它的。比如Mark Lamont Hill聊80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更对黑人重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kier Games主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不安全的坦诚对话，但你是跟一个懂行的持牌专业人士在进行对话。有多少男人穿着铠甲。
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力并不意味着你需要去这样做。在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星Clayton Eckerd被指控生了双胞胎。但这段怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定测试两次对吧，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了一大批网络侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Rancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。Greg Gillespie和Michael Rancini。我惊呆了。我是Stephanie Young。这是《Love Trapped》。Laura，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，Laura Owens终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个IHeart播客。保证是人类制作。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。